un peu plus d'un an après la sortie de
fantômas andré hunebelle dans les
studios de billancourt met en scène la
suite de l'oeuvre de marcel à la phantom
as revient on y retrouve jean marais
louis de funès jacques deen âme et
mylène demongeot plein de bons joueurs
qui vous a envoyé cette très jolie robe
c'est fantômas c'est un thomas c'est
pourquoi bien parce que je savais que je
suis toujours photographes mais je tombe
dans les filets de forme de masse et
fantômas depuis le premier film est
amoureux de moi et un moment donné il
m'a complètement à sa merci heger doit
lui obéir complètement et alors je
reçois une invitation prenait un mâle
robe et je dois me rendre à six qui
entraîne fandor jean marc et c'est ce
qui est en panne de finesse à ma
poursuite
il arrive à me sauver c'est pour ça que
nous entourons tous moi en sherazade oui
en napoléon et un garçon à l'issue du
bal masqué 30 au mas a réussi à attirer
dans son antre le décor a coûté 500
mille francs
le commissaire jules fandor élèves
pour jean marais et louis de funès le
second comme le premier fantômas
représente une grande dépense physique
sur le plan athlétique sera aussi
difficile que lors du premier je crois
pas pour nos assiettes
- j'ai eu la joie vais la jouer la
trouille elle a peur de monter en moto
derrière jean wauthier nord il me dit
j'ai passé mécanisme places
matérialisées par watts chacune sur
l'éruption mais ce qui était étrange que
tu avais plus peur avec un break avec
moi je t'ai dit jeudi
mais si avec moi qui devrais m'en et il
m'a dit ah ben non elle après mehiaoui
après par la suite mais je marchais dans
le fera mais ça reste à vous en
parachute tenu par le fonds du pantalon
est ce que vous espérez finir ce film en
étant tous les deux ou est-ce qu'une
grille un petit doute dérangés pour la
troisième version